what's up look at Oise trailer
commentaries where we talk about the
honest trailer that you hopefully just
watch bring the energy today yeah I can
about rampage oh yeah we're gonna talk
about rampage
we're gonna watch rampage the video game
is a different hand gesture - that said
if you stick around to the end you'll
see some deleted scenes cut some stuff
out of this one I recall and then but
before then I mean we're gonna talk
about rampage yep that was a movie it's
a goofy movie that's it that was a goofy
movie not as good as the goofy movie or
a goofy movie excuse me but it was a
goofy movie yeah I feel like now we
should have made the alt title a goofy
movie like goofy movie there wasn't
really a good father-son dynamic though
which in Iraq between George and the
rock and all good point but then who's
powerline the audience brother yeah
throw a few songs in there and you're
you cold yeah this was a look this is a
dumb I think all of our takes was as a
dumb popcorn the CGI thing and if you
meet it at its own level it's
entertaining and if you have any higher
expectations you're disappointed it's
pretty stupid
it's priestess it's really bad I love
that the first the script had to have
said for just from the way the movie the
script literally must have said fade in
space
I found myself consistently
readjusting my expectations yeah cuz
they were low going in and yeah like
fade in space and then a monkey and a
wolf would be fighting each other like I
was just kept going oh okay yeah now
this was like a more wholesome
equivalent of just being in like the
adult section of a video store where
it's just like you know why you're here
you're not lost looking for a comms like
come on we both know why you were you
for you know you wanted to watch the
monkey punch the rock punched the
alligator
that's why we're all here it didn't go
full so if it had gone full-blown all
the way everything it should have been
would have had we all agreed on this
foot rock yeah rock fighting the
crocodile at the end and we did not get
that it's not in the honest trailer
which we should have put in there is a
moment where the rock is shot yes and
he's shot right next to a canister of
the go big juice that the scientific
term that they used to get large doctor
science and with doctor science
developed and we all had a fleeting
moment where we thought the way he's
gonna fix this is he is going to become
a giant monster and he is going to
wrestle 2 to 3 giant animals in downtown
everything in the movie has led up to
that making sense to him and George like
straight up tag-team wrestling yes
monster Sears Tower the rock bottom or
like the people's elbow assisted rock
bottom yeah the gorilla gets the lizard
on his shoulders
rock bottom up the Sears Tower like I
guess rampage er and page here here and
page World Tour yeah this has really
stayed true to the spirit of the video
game which I do fondly remember it was a
good quarter gobbler you know you'd
punch and put in a quarter and just this
one is interesting cuz like that is a
game where it's like how do you adapt
this like it's not like a Tomb Raider
where there's a story it is literally
just you get on the building and you
downward punch until your melon to make
it guy eventually yeah yeah and you just
hope that you don't turn into a naked
guy before player 2 does the way you
adapt that is to pretty much just go
direct to screen yeah we liked the part
where the military's shooting at the
monsters when they're punching the
buildings yeah cut print dance old yeah
all right well let's see the old honest
trailer for it cuz I know there's plenty
of dumb thoughts we had about this dump
[Music]
you've seen the rock fight giant animals
escape the jungle and navigate a
crumbling city in a helicopter
now watch the rock fight giant animals
who've escaped the jungle while
navigating a crumbling city in a
helicopter before you see him get chased
by a helicopter into a crumbling
building dang got make so many movies
the honest Rio for his last one comes
out the same week as his new it ran
pause it's making the same movie a lot
these days you've seen skyscraper dan I
have similar in the sense that I don't
know what I can say it might not be
tomorrow by the time this comes out
anyway I will say it is similar in the
sense that it involves the rock being a
very strong likable guy
t-shirt who fights large things in crazy
situation all right you know even no
matter how bad they get I still there's
still something about all of these
movies that I can't just like just like
them completely it's weird I'm just like
his characters he comes out completely
unscathed yeah of all of these movies
yeah yeah I don't know it's like
Baywatch I came out of that like alright
Dwayne he's such a great guy off camera
and it's cuz well I wouldn't say the
same about this but usually he's giving
a hundred and ten percent
always always I've never seen the rock
phone in it never not once even in the
worst movie imaginable
he's always 100 percent yeah yeah yeah
I'd say you know yeah yeah yeah that's
why succeeds it's like it doesn't matter
what it it doesn't matter he's gonna
give it a hundred percent yeah so that's
the secret give 110 percent wake up at
4:00 in the morning eat a fish fish
burger whatever he doesn't do 1700 reps
go back to sleep
yeah alright keep going based on the 80s
arcade game where you slap a button
until your giant eight turns into a tiny
head guy comes a field that's only
slightly less ridiculous
with action that feels like it was drawn
up by a little kid with a box of crayons
and dialogue that feels like it was
written by a little kid with a box of
crayons because all of our research was
on that space station really make any
line eat the raw he's your everyday
average primatologist poacher Hunter x
Special Forces former helicopter pilot
program the George gets infected with
outer space growth hormone he'll have to
use every skill he learned communicating
with Vin Diesel on the set of fast aid
they wouldn't even talk to each other
there's a rampage yeah there's rampage
style beef between the two of them
that's why he's doing hobbes and shod
and and why Tyrese had a meltdown and
like the holdfast families come come
apart at the seams yeah yeah plus it's a
joke
we're playing into the even diesel
appears to be dumb why would you say
that Dan his character his characters
often are quite clueless or or full of
themselves in a sense of not being able
to really they're caricatures mmm so you
play into the caricature that perhaps
the rock would have to be very basic in
his communication I don't know what went
down in that trailer though on the set
of fast eight but could Vin Diesel do
rampage and come out being solid i would
watch Vin Diesel in this movie yeah just
as easily like this is a total like for
this film you can totally swap the two
cuz I don't think you need to
particularly like poacher and had a
corona cuz well the rock gives 110
percent fun like Vin Diesel gives 110
percent serious like yeah yes Georgie
get in a sky
the Vin Diesel version he would have
grown to 200 feet but there would have
been no humor involved in it yeah very
stuff seriously - he would have done a
kickflip with a building
probably there's a note reality where
heated rampage and the rock does the
last witch hunter see that that's
freaking Morty that portal gun that
reality I have two brothers let's keep
going
Lily could have done it all himself
because just like most of his other
films The Rock's character is literally
invulnerable to moonlight as she plays a
scientist who put every animals DNA into
a cocktail shaker just to see what would
happen reported back DNA the growth
weight of a blue whale strength the
Buran oestrus beetle did she work with
dr. Henry Wu capable extremely
generation and Jeffrey Dean Morgan the
government agent who's more down south
to Anaheim today huh 20 years in the
cast of deliverance at a Cracker Barrel
great my serve on a competitive flag
hubcap thank you for getting this old
cowboy off that plane Oh Jeffrey you
bless your heart but you're from Seattle
y'all need to tone it down a little bit
were you both southerners were you
offended by his his South Face him
really sounded up it's really just he
seems to only have one southern perfor
even had them Deline
yeah the Leegin as I called the nican
lien got like a giant like penis pistol
which is just sitting like right there
this huge gun I think it's char last I
think it's very charming it's like some
guy did community theater it's like the
true West day and like just put on this
big ridiculous yeah I just imagine the
casting session for that he like sits
down and he's like so what are your
thoughts on this character and they're
like we love what
do as negan yep if the script just said
like government guide southern saunters
in or song yeah or if it doesn't say
he's a real [ __ ] of the walk
he's like wait this character could use
a little more flavor like what if I plan
from the deepest south so deep I want to
see jeopardy Morgan do one of those
really cheesy one-man shows where is
like my family man what a cast of
characters why don't you spell this dog
that's the name of the show rampage go
so if you're looking for a pile of
one-liners and CGI guerrilla fights held
together by duct tape and a likeable
star Oh [ __ ]
speaking of like bull I like that the
rock changed the ending to the movie
completely both screenwriters are all
three I don't know how many of they were
like no it's good that George dies at
the end it's like he made the ultimate
sacrifice and darks like no that's not
dying
no like nobody makes sense for the
stories like people don't go this movie
to like watch the monkey die like they
watch it that's fair totally dies and
then it's just like I would love to see
The Rock's version of King Kong yeah
where it's just like yeah it wasn't
airplanes it was Beauty killed the betta
are you are you
[Music]
[Laughter]
there'd be entertained not not to feel
down what a cast of characters so like
bar you'll love the rocks latest city
destroying adventure but if you're
looking for logic and depth from the
monster punching video game movie then
brother
you're about as dumb as a pair of
scissors yep that's George of the jungle
she destroyed a classic
[Laughter]
I do think the rock well that's that's
neither here nor thing I do think he
let's just say he turns down multiple
women in this movie most movies or
easily as a family and there's not this
one
he's a single you're attractive
paleontologists who
it's like why put in the scenes of like
there's that the co-ed at the beginning
and then Naomi Harris there like will
they won't they in both times it's like
no they won't
he lives for George maybe it's just
winking some random person yeah yeah
he's not a people person
no he's not he's a confirmed bachelor
that's all anyways let's see some scenes
from rampage forget the giant monsters
because the real villains are the twin
CEOs of energized two morons who
secretly created giant monsters for
profit lost track of them and plans to
recoup their losses by luring them to
their personal offices in downtown
Chicago whatever getting mad at a dumb
evil plan in this movie would be like
getting mad it wouldn't acting for Malin
Akerman we all know what we signed up
for
has to be me boss what I mean
yeah it's over line you know we we felt
bad about the calling her out by name
and the Watchmen it was trailer
something we do yeah but uh
and she wasn't look she was camping it
up in this movie it wasn't wooden and I
hear she's really good in billions yeah
so Malin I've never had a problem with
just Watchmen this is just watch me
working on the acting and Watchmen no
less emotional it was like action so
anyway the fight is gonna come in and
he's just gonna be like wow that was
great that was great I'm sure it was
great Billy Crone UPS good man Hurley
yeah you're right there's some good
performances which is why she stands out
any much what else do we cut starring a
Gary Stu rock bottom the snore peon King
yon of the Planet of the Apes
r.i.p coco not so Thin Lizzy fraud Zilla
Lizzie magie der Brau little rock little
rock let me in what's that hungry like
the wolf big bad wolf Joe Maggio cameo
what a litter like invaders here lost
billions and South face [ __ ] roid rage
oh that's it we are oh yeah that was
their only tag wasn't it oh yeah I
remember I remember there might be a
little something extra even further
extra do you guys catch the hit now now
I see the hidden Allen there's one tell
us below
yeah anything else any any final
thoughts on rampage no man this is just
a goofy movie there's only so much to
say about it kind of came and went
through through my body and soul and out
the other end and I don't know would you
see a rampage - do you care yeah yeah
would I didn't I I don't as I recall I
never viewed it I didn't I didn't I
think I said I'm not gonna recommend it
but I'm also not gonna tell you not to
go see it so I would feel the same way
about rampage - yeah this was not as
aggressively I not ironically
intentionally stupid as as some others
yeah I want him to take some time I want
the rock to take some time off okay just
for himself it's not because I'm like
man making movies man he's just he's
doing a lot and some don't we're now now
yeah yeah I just take the time you and
Jason Statham need together you know
whatever yes I'm excited for Hobson
cricket or whatever oh it's gonna be
amazing okay
sounds like cricket on the brain okay
guys next week we have another exciting
oz trailer coming at you it won't be as
loud as the one you saw this week we
might not have much to say about that
one and not even have much to say about
it either see what we do right here next
week on Australia commentaries
you
[Music]